[Musique]
le gros sera sera il y en a eu tellement
ratifié à base de serpents globalement
c'est des gros sera sera voilà donc je
fais plus droit aux serpents j'ai eu
droit aux arrêts mais j'ai eu droit aux
scorpions au sourit marie drot france
rage c'est quand je tourne ce de manière
totalement si vignoble
[Applaudissements]
si on dirty dancing avec mon ami mokhtar
qui me qui nous jettent par terre
les grecs
[Musique]
ces caméras cachées ou le malheur de
dire une chose épouvantable à mon père
concernant régate
[Musique]
j'ai eu ces deux phrases regrettables
vous ai dit qu'elle avait les yeux qui
sentait ça c'était vraiment l'homme de
ma vie de zula ou de manière plus chez
moi après 4 heures c'est une grosse
rattrape alors le jour où évidemment
j'ai fait la chute la plus longue au
monde je crois je me suis bien tapé la
fille la plus grosse qu'à sera ça c'est
dur de l'oublier j'ai tenté à la corde à
sauter
[Applaudissements]
on se retrouve et le pantalon sur les
chevilles
oh mon dieu je ne compte que cours je ne
tombe plus quoi j'étais déguisé en
highlander que j'étais face à blake aime
les tonnes de mazout des kadogo dont
j'avais dit je n'appréciais pas beaucoup
les chansons j'ai pris une perte dans la
figure il en redonner il enrhumé terme
et terme était depuis j'ai sympathisé
avec black aime parce que au moment de
l'histoire de verdun il a eu quelques
soucis donc je vais apporter mon soutien
je trouve c'est quelqu'un de très très
bien donc en fait c'est une race track
qui s'est transformée finalement au bon
souvenir à plus grosse grâce à ses
récents voix près de retrait basse et
lara sera des rats sera très gros sera
sera c'était le saut en parachute qui
s'est transformée en énorme marca
[Musique]
j'ai eu la peur de ma vie mais un
bonheur immense et je remercie de
m'avoir comme une pousse à y faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]